jeudi vers la ville gueye puis chers
amis et la rue du progrès sont
américaines
dans sa première en bleu un plaisir de
dépassement désir de grandir plan social
tout ce qu'on a fait à la baie james et
sensationnel c'est grandiose
les fier de se remémorer la clé de la
vie
c'était le 30 avril 1971 au colisée de
québec
c'était bien tous j -h les gens criaient
à plus de 7 devant des milliers de
militants libéraux
robert bourassa a annoncé le projet du
siècle
ça c'est le soir de la victoire guy
langlois est à l'époque son chef de
cabinet a pas longtemps que la crise
d'octobre était arrivé six mois avant
c'est un peu un événement qui venait
donner un peu d'espoir aux gens en
général et puis au moment de faire ce
libéral en plus c'était le projet du
siècle d'un homme pressé le support a
fait réellement forcer la main à hydro
québec pour accélérer les études et
accélérer le développement de la baie
james
c'est un projet qui frappe l'imaginaire
québécois parce qu'on parle d'un projet
de près de 6 milliards ce qui
correspondrait aujourd'hui à 40
milliards d'investissements ainsi ce
méga-projet de plusieurs centrales
hydroélectriques sur les rivières de la
région de la baie james va s'échelonner
en trois phases de 1973 jusqu'à près
2000 2500 km de routes des ponts des
aéroports
un véritable chantier pharaonique
j'ai deux alimente actuellement le
québec
la deadline est venu propulsé
hydro-québec dans des dans des ordres de
grandeur qui qu'ils n'avaient aucune
mesure avec celle qui existait dans la
baie james et au dessus de 7000
mégawatts de capacités de production
c'est au dessus de 5 1 % de nos
capacités à aujourd'hui en 2021
c'est dire l'immensité créer un tel
chantier à l'état voire évidemment des
impacts sur l'environnement
[Musique]
juste la première phase disons de ce
projet de budget glossées c'est plus de
trois rivières ans qu'on voit qu'on va
détourner pour emmener dans un immense
bassin qui fait quoi 175 mille
kilomètres carrés
on dénature complètement tous toute
cette zone aux commentaires
il y à un demi siècle outre
l'environnement et autochtone n'était
pas au centre des préoccupations des
protagonistes du projet monsieur bourse
est tellement convaincu de l'importance
de ce projet qu'il avait décidé de
foncer et de régler les problèmes au fur
et à mesure aussi se présenteraient par
la suite le principal défi pour le
gouvernement vers le mans bourassa c'est
avec l'écrit en seul hic c'est sur le
tronc développe ses projets là sur le
trottoir créer et sur leur territoire
innu si michelin grimpent eux ce futur
proche des 72 l'écrivons en cours et
vont gagner une première manche
judiciaire
si bien que le gouvernement va devoir
s'asseoir avec les créent les et nous
pour négocier une entente
cette convention prévoit des mesures à
londres partait destinée à protéger
leurs économies autant que leur culture
c'est la fameuse convention de la baie
james qui arrivera en 1975 sa touche en
fait leurs droits ancestraux de chasse
de pêche de cueillette de trappes
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer un projet
comme ça peut-être est-ce qu'on pourrait
l'organiser
ce serait extrêmement difficiles et dans
tous les cas de figure la manière dont
ça a été fait ne pourrait ne pourrait
plus exister aujourd'hui ce que l'on
fait aujourd'hui avec les communautés
autochtones est bien meilleur que ce que
l'on faisait il ya cinq ans in
extraordinairement meilleure qu'à 50 et
l'électricité y rien d'autre que ça des
électrons en mouvement ok donc
l'électricité cédée électrons en
mouvement et je pense que je fais à sel
et c'est ce soir que savais pas ça
christine beaulieu a beaucoup fouillé le
dossier du producteur d'électricité dans
sa pièce
j'aime hydro et on a développé un génie
au québec on a bien fait nos barrages
sont solides et n le cui fonctionne
c'est vraiment du bon travail du bord du
génie humain extraordinaire on a un
surplus d'énergie important au québec et
qu'il faudrait arrêter de construire de
nouvelles centrales électriques
aujourd'hui 50 à plus tard faut se
demander plus tôt
est-ce qu'on a encore besoin est ce que
c'est encore nécessaire de faire ses
grands chantiers hydroélectriques sur
notre territoire pour créer de l'énergie
au québec
au fil des ans l'artiste militante dit
avoir gagné l'oreille d'hydro-québec et
depuis peu celle de sophie brochu acquis
et le pose cette question est-ce que
c'est par étapes par le deuil de
construire de nouveaux grands projets
hydroélectriques comme cet écart à noah
des centaines de kilomètres de
territoires avec le mode veille
il ya en tongs et doux
et je pense qu'il est fou surtout pour
tourner dos faut comprendre que nous
avons et construire à partir de ce que
nous avons y'a pas léser les gens qui
s'est assis dans ma chaise aujourd'hui
il est vrai que ça n'arrivera plus
jamais parce que ce serait deviner le
futur
demain matin s'il n'y a plus de pétrole
dans le monde et qu'on a besoin
d'électricité peut-être que nous
voudrons trouver des façons de faire des
aménagements qui sont mieux fait plus
intelligent alors quelle est la suite
pour hydro-québec
selon christine beaulieu le grand
chantier du futur d'hydro-québec se
déplace maintenant dans les foyers
québécois on pourrait tous et autres
contribué au réseau électrique
est-ce qu'on pressent installer des
panneaux solaires sur nos toits est ce
que ma voiture électrique il y en a de
plus en plus on notre territoire à une
batterie c'est une source d'énergie qui
s'ajoute dans notre réseau si on avait
des prises bi directionnelle c'est à
dire que je ne fais pas que chargé ma
voiture mais ma voiture peut charger ma
maison ça ferait une avancée formidable
sophie brochu y croit aussi jusqu'à un
certain point
l'énergie éolienne l'énergie solaire
elle est disponible
quand tu es ventes et quand il fait
chaud et si aujourd'hui on peut
réfléchir à déployer ces nouvelles
énergies
l'usagé complémentaires et concurrentiel
c'est parce qu'on pût se chient
justement sur les réservoirs que nous
avons créés
cinquante ans plus tard ce projet
titanesque eux continuent de faire la
fierté et d'éclairer la moitié du québec
la production d'électricité est
aujourd'hui à un autre tournant de son
existence la développer l'exporter tout
en respectant davantage des enjeux
environnementaux et communautaires à
suivre dans les 50 prochaines années